después de 2 años de ausencia por la
pandemia él está aquí en todas partes y
al mismo tiempo Santa Claus o Papá Noel
cómo se le conoce a este mítico
personaje dejó su tradicional trineo y
descendió en helicóptero sobre las
favelas de Río de Janeiro para
distribuir alimentos a las personas más
necesitadas y color de su piel género
alegría entre los presentes
un Papa Noel negro es lindo que
representa a mí representa a todos
porque es muy raro era un Papa Noel
negro solo veo los blancos estoy feliz
se trata de una iniciativa de una ONG y
como está cientos de visitas se llevaron
a cabo en todo Brasil en vísperas de la
Navidad para llegar a los lugares más
vulnerables casi de manera simultánea a
unos 5000 km al este del continente en
la capital de Perú la legendaria
personalidad fue recibida con júbilo por
cientos de niños a los que entrego
dulces y juguetes desde 2005 julio
arroyo recaudar donaciones para llevar
alegría a los más pequeños
es una alegría inmensa porque son ellos
que valoran lo que tú entregas
[Música]
no que sienten esa que llega su
superhéroe navideño en Europa Papá Noel
llego hasta hospitales infantiles donde
decenas de niños han tenido que pasar la
Navidad internados desde la ventana el
equipo de rescate alpino de Italia
saludo a los pequeños y en Barcelona en
España el espectáculo estuvo
protagonizado por integrantes del Cuerpo
de Bomberos
por segundo año consecutivo las
restricciones implementadas para
contener el covid-19 han opacado gran
parte de las celebraciones sin embargo
iniciativas cómo estás han demostrado
que el espíritu navideño no se ha visto
afectado
[Música]